well security measures are crucial to
handle crowds like at fremont street and
on the strip eight news now got a rare
look into how one property is working to
keep you safe and keep tourists focused
on enjoying their time here in las vegas
find it k-9 units sniffing out any
potential hazards around vehicles near
the caesars forum conference center
it's part of a special exercise between
caesars entertainment fema and homeland
security these functional exercises they
give us an opportunity
to really test our process
our policies our procedures and our
training caesar's corporation's vp of
security eric golibowski says planning
started last year as they continue to
enhance security measures across the
board back back back 8 news now got an
exclusive look at some of the exercises
including this scenario about a possible
shooting and how the armed special
response team and the k-9 unit responded
back back back bring one in online it's
all for really the guests so they can
come here not even think about safety
have an enjoyable time when they come to
las vegas golibowski says all casino
security teams are constantly in touch
about any trends or potential risks on
the horizon he says security and
evacuation plans are crucial that we're
continuing to evolve our surveillance
teams and integrate them into these
critical incidents so they can assist us
in mitigating any type of situation that
occurs jonathan alvarez with protective
force international says communication
is key for security teams especially
when working with other agencies
physically training is a big key and
mentally training for all these
situations so consistency is the key
as the pandemic restrictions roll back
and international flights pick up these
special response teams will be standing
by and ready to act if needed we're
doing bigger and better things and
bringing in more tourism and we're
prepared to you know secure that
environment so people feel safe to come
out and enjoy it
well here's something that we learned
that perhaps you at home may not know of
top security leaders meet monthly to
exchange practices and trends it's
called the las vegas security chiefs
association now their mission is to
exchange communications between each
other and law enforcement with of course
making sure visitors and workers are
safe